foreign
but other people as well let's just look
first how it looks like violation of
Human Rights not in paper but in reality
everyday reality in Ukraine after the
Russian invasion I want to show you the
Ukrainian City the center of our salt
industry this is how Bahamut used to be
and this is what it is after many months
of assaults of Russians against the city
there were 80 000 people living in the
city now only 500 000 remains among them
150 children every day these people go
for humanitarian Aid and water and a
heavy shell and they die every day
they are evacuated by special services
and volunteers selfishly and the
evacuations are dangerous
not so far ago an American volunteer was
killed because the ambulance he worked
on was shot at one little boy was
evacuated when his parents were killed
by the shelling and then the police had
to come up to a special rescue operation
to save the boy what are we
um people in this audience and the
cities have in common and with uh and
the volunteers these are human rights in
any city of Ukraine in London Berlin New
York or New York
we have the right
not to be killed or tortured
and not to be belong to pieces
adults and six children
in all their diversity destroyed by
Russia
and this is what human rights violations
look like in the occupied in Zoom when
it was liberated by the Armed Forces
of ukrainians left behind by the
Russians just like that before in
Butcher and Europeans
city
offices
there were three children
during a routine visit to the doctor
[Music]
and was in their own country
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
let's finally listen to them thank you
[Applause]
powerful words to start us off today
uh now we will hear from his Excellency
the foreign minister of Ukraine
Mr culeba you have the floor Excellency
thank you
Excellence is colleagues ladies and
gentlemen I'm grateful to 45 countries
that helped make this event happen
as well as to everyone who joined us in
person or online today
this event
is a wake-up call
it is our call for everyone to work
together to save people's lives and
protect their rights and freedoms no
matter where they are in Russian
captivity
being deported or stuck in temporarily
occupied parts of Ukraine
Russia's full-scale invasion of my
country caused the worst human crisis in
Europe since World War II
Russia has committed all kinds of crimes
against the Ukrainian people for the
past nine years violating
every bit of the universal Declaration
of Human Rights
forcible deportation filtration camps
arbitrary detentions enforced
disappearances torture summary
executions
conflict-related sexual violence attacks
on civilians and critical infrastructure
with missiles and drones
this is not a full list of crimes and of
Against Humanity and war crimes
committed by the Russian Federation
thousands of Ukrainian prisoners of war
and civilians remain in deplorable
conditions in illegal detention on
Ukraine's temporarily occupied
territories or in Russia
but the most deplorable crime is the
forcible transfers and deportations of
Ukrainian children to Russia
away from their families please turn on
your camera
and caregivers
hundreds of people are on broadcasting
you into the meeting can you please turn
on your camera thank you
be happy to show me if you show me the
button I have to push
according to the report's findings this
networking Network includes at least 43
facilities that stretch from one end of
Russia to the other
32 of them are used for so-called
political re-education
and all levels of Russian government are
involved in this genocide this horror
must stop and those responsible must be
held fully accountable
to stop it and punish perpetrators we
all need to join forces governments
International Community International
organizations ngos activists media
experts and of course legal community
ladies and gentlemen we must not forget
that Russian aggression against Ukraine
started nine years ago in February 2014
when Russia invaded Crimea
failure to respond decisively to this
breach of the international order paved
the way for what is now the largest
International armed conflict
in Europe since World War II
unpunished evil Returns on a bigger
scale the reason behind Russian crimes
during these nine years boils down to
one word
impunity
Russia felt it could get away with all
of this therefore the Cure against
Russian crimes boils down to one word
too
and this word is justice
we therefore support the investigation
by the office of the prosecutor of the
international criminal court and are
grateful to prosecutor Han and his
team's efforts
we are fully committed to continuing to
work together with the ICC in the fight
against impunity
we look forward to seeing the
deliverables of the ICC investigation in
particular indictments and arrest
warrants for those Russians who
committed war crimes crimes against
humanity and genocide
accountability for core International
crimes committed in Ukraine shall be
comprehensive there shall be no gaps or
loopholes in it Russia's political and
Military leadership must face Justice
too
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is a crime
in and of itself a flagrant violation of
the U.N Charter's prohibition on the use
of force against territorial Integrity
of states
international criminal justice has an
important achievement has important
achievements in addressing genocide
crimes against humanity and war crimes
but there is no International court or
tribunal which can exercise jurisdiction
over the crime of aggression against
Ukraine
we must close this accountability Gap
and establish a special tribunal which
will be able to do that
the crime obviously happened the Russian
invasion of Ukraine will go down in
history as a textbook example of the
crime of aggression
we cannot let it go unpunished
this would cause enormous damage to the
international legal order and the rule
of law
this is why it is so important to
establish a special Tribunal aggression
is the mother of all crimes meaning that
all war crimes crime swing Against
Humanity and genocide stem from it
together with our friends and partners
we gathered a core group on the
establishment of the special tribunal
the group will play a leading role and
become an ultimate platform for holding
legal discussions finding Solutions and
Paving the way forward I therefore
encourage you to join the core group and
make your contribution to the
establishment of the special Tribunal
as of now an international center for
the protection for the prosecution of
the crime of aggression in Ukraine will
be established in The Hague with the
objective to coordinate investigation
preserve and store evidence for future
trials and we are grateful to our
colleagues from the European Union and
of course the Netherlands for this move
we look forward to the rapid
establishment and beginning of
operations of this Center
this is an important step forward to
ensuring accountability for the crime of
aggression
ukrainians hear the powerful voices of
the entire Democratic World in our
support which should be strengthened by
Resolute coordinated actions and I'm
confident that our dialogue today will
contribute to the creation of new
effective initiatives and formats of
cooperation and human rights protection
and accountability
there is obviously no one-size-fits-all
approach to all situations and many
existing recipes no longer work
it is high time to introduce new
approaches and tools and we shouldn't be
afraid of it
let's do it together and prove that
everything that seems impossible is
ultimately possible when Justice is our
goal thank you
[Applause]
we will now hear from the foreign
minister foreign minister hakstra of the
Netherlands your Excellency you have the
floor
thank you chair and ladies and gentlemen
I cannot get the image out of my hands
the conversation I had with Sasha
a 12 year old boy who has seen more
misery in his life than we probably ever
see in ours
he told me how his eye had been injured
during a Russian missile attack
and how he had been captured by Russian
forces separated from his mother
and tools that had that he had been
adopted by Russians because he had no
parents
committed in Ukraine
accountability that puts survivors needs
from the center
with a water tides judicial process that
ensures that Russia doesn't get away
with such crimes
and it is to this end we're supporting
the Quest for accountability
we're doing this bilaterally with
Ukraine by International coordination
and investigative mechanisms and of
course fire the ICC
and for this quest to succeed
we also need watertight evidence
and that is why the Netherlands is
sending another two forensic
investigation missions to Ukraine
and I would like to invite all state
parties to the Rome statute present here
today to contribute to this effort and
basically to do the same
as I've said nobody
should get away with crimes like these
and therefore we strongly support the
establishment of the international
center for the prosecution of the crime
of aggression
descender to be located in The Hague
will collect evidence that can be used
to eventually try Russian leadership
and analys will host a register of
damage claims rising from Russian's
aggression
and we will be and we will soon be
launching a dialogue group to facilitate
the coordination of accountability
initiatives together with Ukraine the EU
and the ICC
and here as well I would like to invite
all of you to join and support these
accountability initiatives
dear friends
we must do all we can to prevent further
Injustice
and by doing everything in our power to
return children like Sasha to their
current country to their parents
and to their loved ones
and that is why the Netherlands joined
forces with Ukraine and Germany to make
sure the world knows that Russia is
systematically abducting Ukrainian
children
and why we firmly support the new
sanctions that EU is planning
and I would urge everyone in this room
today to join us in condemning these
appalling crimes
ladies and gentlemen such as grandmother
traveled through Poland Lithuania Latvia
and Russia and then into Russian
occupied eastern Ukraine to get her
grandson back
and she succeeded because she refused to
give up
Ukrainian people are still standing
because they refuse to give up
and we must help them with the same
resolve
and we must do so not only for the
people of Ukraine
but for the future of all of us
because the core values that bring us
together here today of the United
Nations are at stake
there can never be peace and I said it
again there can never be peace in a
world where crime and Brute Force
Prevail over Justice thank you
[Applause]
thank you Excellency uh now we will hear
from the from foreign minister ransula
from uh Estonia
your Excellency you have the floor
yes thank you Excellence is guests there
the Metro
I deliver the statement on behalf of the
group of friends of accountability
following the aggression against Ukraine
consisting of 1949 member states and the
European Union
in one horrendous year Russia's war of
aggression has caused intolerable misery
innocent deaths and destruction of
Ukraine
reportedly over 1.6 million ukrainians
have been forcibly taken to Russia we
have witnessed images and reports of
indiscriminate killings of civilians as
well as unlawful attacks on civilian
infrastructure sexual and gender-based
violence and shocking reports of
abductions of children
such actions are unacceptable and
constitute a violation of international
law
wherever they occur and must be met with
the same strong response whenever they
occur
today we have we will have the
opportunity to hear first-hand
testimonies from survivors and experts
in the eyes of the public
The credibility of our institutions
including the UN
rests upon our Collective response to
ensure that all perpetrators are held to
full account for the egregious
violations of international law still
playing out before us and to defend the
rights of victims and survivors
reports of conflict related sexual
violence in Ukraine targeted most
frequently at women girls are of
particular concern conflict-related
sexual violence including rape used as a
tactic of war is a blatant violation and
abuse of international humanitarian law
and international human human rights law
and it can constitute a war crime and
crimes against humanity
it must be met with effective
accountability measures in this regard
we welcome the cooperation between the
government of Ukraine and the office of
the special representative for sexual
violence and conflict and we commend the
important work of Civil Society
organizations
we are also deeply concerned by reports
of Russian forces having relocated at
least 6 000 Ukrainian children to camps
and Facilities across Russia for forced
adoption and military training such
actions are in clear violation of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law and may
constitute war crimes and crimes against
humanity we must continue to defend the
human rights of every child and we
welcome today's discussion on this
particular issue
fighting impunity must be at the core of
our International response we commend
all efforts to ensure accountability in
particular the opening of an
investigation by the prosecutor of the
ICC
Additionally the establishment of the
independent International Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine the osc
Moscow mechanism or the irony of name
the U.N human rights monitoring Mission
and the creation of an international
center for the prosecution of the crime
of aggression are important
contributions to the Quest for justice
the group of friends also highlights the
important efforts of all other actors
who contribute to accountability efforts
for Ukraine including National
investigators and Civil Society actors
collecting and preserving evidence
while we wait for the ongoing legal
processes which will take time
we cannot ignore the independent reports
and testimonies we have in front of us
Ukrainian authorities have prosecuted
and tried more than 20 people for war
crimes
the independent International Commission
of inquiry on Ukraine has found
reasonable grounds to conclude that an
array of war crimes and violations of
human rights and international
humanitarian law have been committed in
Ukraine
the experts of the USC Moscow mechanism
concluded that International
humanitarian law and international human
rights law has been extensively violated
in the conflict in Ukraine
the mission also concluded that some of
these violations were likely to amount
to war crimes and crimes against
humanity
the ohchr monitoring Mission has
documented violations of international
humanitarian law and international human
rights law such as unlawful killings
including summer executions of civilians
in more than 30 settlements in Kiev
Germany and Sumi region the numbers from
the latest report published yesterday
are devastating highlighting that the
human cost of the war in Ukraine has
left at least 8 000 civilians dead and
more than 13 000 injured over the past
12 months
today we will hear first-hand
testimonies that International Community
can't ignore we need to continue to call
out violations and condemn what is
taking place
we recall the order on provisional
measures by the international court of
justice of 16th March last year that
Russia shall immediately suspend the
military operations that in it commenced
on 24th February last year in the
territory of Ukraine the principal
judicial organ of the United Nations has
stated it clearly we call on Russia to
comply to stop the war we as the
International Community must show that
we will not tolerate any country
trampling on the U.N Charter thank you
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency uh now we will
give the floor to foreign minister
Flores of Guatemala your Excellency you
have the floor
thank you Ambassador Harper for giving
me the floor
victory theory of Human Rights
Justice for Ukraine and accountability
that is the reason that we are here dear
friends and excellencies this is the
moment that we need to strongly condemn
the unjustified and provoked aggression
by the Russian Federation against the
territorial integrity and the population
of Ukraine
these actions constitute a flagrant
violation of the United States Nations
Charter we are extremely concerned what
is happening today but we represent the
voice of the ones that doesn't have a
voice today
the numbers that we're going to hear
today can be not tolerated it is
admissible and we should reprehend it
for the reason that we are here together
to Prevail on peace
the U.N General Assembly has recognized
that Russia must be held accountable for
the violations of the international law
international humanitarian law and human
rights
we are going to appeal today
to all of you that we can come together
with conclusions that can be able to
allow us to bring Russia accountable for
what is happening
we are very concerned about the increase
of the numbers that we have of people
that needs human Aid and rights that we
need to be able to pervade throughout
this year the Intensive hostilities by
Russia has caused destruction death and
griefness to other civilians and
including women and children forcing to
evacuate their homes as a result
ukrainians are without access of food
drinking water medical assistant and
basic services
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
it is extremely alarming that Russia
military operation has not cease
including the increase of launchings of
different types of missiles against
civilian population frankly violating
the international law international
human
humanitarian law including threats of a
possible use of nuclear weapons
the president of the Republic of
Guatemala Dr Alejandro yamate fire
myself witnessed firsthand the
atrocities caused by this aggression
during our visit to Ukraine last year
the scene was devastating
that is why today I call to the
International Community that we need to
be able to work together
to achieve peace and make the necessary
commitments to prevent the arm clashes
between the Nations throughout dialogue
negotiation and peace means provided by
the international law
as a result my country Guatemala
co-facilitate the resolution adopted
last 14 of November that requested the
creation of an International Register of
Damages against Ukraine
Guatemala also co-sponsored the
resolution
49-1 of the Human Rights Council which
established the international
independent Commission of inquiry to
investigate the violation stemming from
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
we have also supported all initiatives
to seek the creation of a special
Tribunal for the crimes
committed of this aggression
at this time
we need to raise the voice to end this
conflict Guatemala joins the call for a
ceasefire to the end hostilities against
civilians in Ukraine
Guatemala as a state that respectfully a
continued to respect international law
and is very proud of the peace vocation
that we have called for diplomacy to be
able to be prevented and even graded
today raise the voice for the ones that
are needed
and the voices is dears no more life
needs to be lost no more civilians needs
to be wounded no more mothers needs to
be able to suffer for the loss of their
children accountability victory for
human rights
is needed is lava Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency uh now we will
turn the floor over to the minister
Jolly uh of Canada uh foreign minister
of Canada uh you're Excellency
thank you Ambassador Harper
um thank you for this opportunity to
join all of you and my friends
[Music]
and other ministers at this essential
event to hear firsthand accounts of some
of the consequences of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine
reality
today ukrainians are not only defending
their country from the evil of Putin and
his enablers they are defending their
rights the principles of the U.N Charter
and the values of freedom and democracy
that so many of us hold dear
there's no option but victory for
Ukraine
Canada will be there to support
Ukraine's fight for freedom for as long
as it takes
and once they win
we will help them to recover
last week I was in Ukraine to reform
just that
I met with courageous and resilient
ukrainians from all walks of life
who are passionate about rebuilding
Ukraine once they are victorious
in our conversation it was clear
for reconstruction to be inclusive and
endearing
it must address both the physical and
invisible impacts of Putin's war on men
women and children victims of the war
and so we must tackle the psychological
marks of the war with the same
seriousness and urgency as the physical
scars
to heal the trauma that has been
inflicted on the population we must
support survivors in Seeking Justice
this pursuit of accountability will be
essential to achieving lasting peace in
Ukraine
the efforts ukrainians are making to
provide relief to their fellow citizens
even as the war rages is inspiring in a
world Awash in too much suffering
it drove home for me the need for the
International Community of all of us
to continue helping Ukraine
let me be clearer Russia's war on
Ukraine is unjustified it is illegal
Russian forces have committed and
continued to commit indiscriminate and
impelling acts across Ukraine they have
destroyed entire cities targeted
hospitals and playgrounds in an act of
incredible horror they have ripped
children away from their homes
they have taken the lives of too many
families
in Ukraine I met with a prosecutor
General to discuss his work to gather
evidence and prosecute those responsible
for crimes linked to the war including
conflict-related sexual violence
he is dealing as we speak with some 60
000 cases
and this number climbs with each passing
day
the details included in each are
horrific yet those figures do not
provide a full picture of the widespread
human suffering occurring each of the
363 days of Putin's War
for every individual who is willing to
tell their story many others go
unreported due to the stigma and
feelings of Shame as mentioned by first
lady Alaska
zelinska a bit earlier and I also met
with Ukrainian police officers
psychologists prosecutors and
investigators who are working to
investigate and prosecute these crimes
while supporting survivors of this
violence encounter will continue to
support them
those responsible for this suffering
will answer further crimes they will be
met with the full force of the law
Canada welcomes Ukraine's case against
Russia at the international court of
justice and we continue to support the
international Criminal Court's efforts
in Ukraine
we have also joined the core group
launched by Ukraine my friend mitro in
examining the proposal to establish a
special tribunal on the crime of
aggression a crime which may not fall
within the scope of existing
institutions
together we will leave no stone unturned
as we identify the most effective ways
to hold Russia accountable for its crime
of aggression
this is also aimed at deterring others
who are watching us considering if they
could ever challenge the rules
the emergency session of the general
assembly will meet today and vote
tomorrow on a resolution on U.N Charter
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
is
and Canada calls on all member states to
support the resolution and through it to
continue supporting the principles of
the UN Charter and the people of Ukraine
thank you
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency uh as each of
our distinguished ministers have noted
essential
uh what is essential is accountability
uh and so one piece of that
accountability is the international
criminal court and we welcome online uh
The Honorable Kareem Khan uh King's
Council and prosecutor at the ICC
distinguished
foreign ministers
and face ladies and gentlemen it's
really a somber moment and it's an awful
and unwanted
necessity
to be assembled together today
as has been said by the distinguished
speakers already
as is no world
that have seen the pictures
that have heard the voices
terrible trauma and suffering has been
to
Ukraine and her people
over the last one year
in May of last year
I was in butcher
outside Saint Peter's Church
if the
then prosecutor General
my team and with the Ukrainian
investigators that were working with
courage
document
the crimes prepared to have been
committed
I saw the body bags
and we heard
and in the subsequent months
investigations conducted by my office
have deepened
in in boredanka
in kharkiv and when I left
I thought
really about left behind because shells
were falling
I left khakif
my small team and we went to Kiev but
Ukrainian innovators and prosecutors
remained
in a city that was on the front line and
this is repeated
across Ukraine
I said very clearly in butcher
that unfortunately and objectively
Ukraine was a crime scene
and the accounts that we have seen
he fortified the conclusion
that manifestly
ever more vividly
we are certain that there are reasonable
grounds to
that Rome statute crimes
appear to have been committed in Ukraine
I've seen and it's been mentioned by the
first little
of Ukraine and others
seen the
pictures
of the injured
regarding the Maternity Ward ward in
barrier Paul or the theater we've seen
and heard accounts of
the targeting
of the grids we've seen and heard
allegations or prisons of war that are
recounting allegations of torture
We Have Heard
and spoken to rituals
who are complaining of sexual
agenda-based violence
we have seen and heard
the predicament of some children
who appear to have been taken across
International borders
and our joint
responsibilities to make sure the law
is on the front lines
it is not an optional x-ray it is not
something that we come to with a degree
of
pedestrian approach we need to act with
dispatch
while the bullets are being fired and as
bombs are falling
because I have seen
either on the border of Poland when
grandmothers and women and children
across the border early on at the end of
February and beginning of March
that the law matters to individuals
whilst many have lost their physical
shelter
they are looking increasingly the law
of them shelter now for what they've
endured
and to mitigate or ameliorate the worst
types of excesses
far too often take place in conflict and
therefore
seriousness of the situation from any
perspective
is well known to everybody
and yet in the despair
of uncertainty
we have also seen numerous times courage
indefatigable energy
and determination
to survive to prosper and to succeed
there is a saying of course that the
darkest part of the night
is just before the dawn
and God Alone knows
whether or not we have seen the worst
but we pray so
but in the midst of the disruption the
uncertainty when the ankability
seem to have been uprooted in so many
places around the world
we do see Rays of Hope
in an unprecedented move
within 48 Hours of my invitation 39
States
spoke with one voice
of the world
that the situation
in Ukraine should be referred
my office
we now have 43 States
we have seen new Partnerships being
built
a foreign minister of the Netherlands
would be hoxtra I have has to be
applauded as does the government Blends
in pioneering with my office a unique
novel rotational model or forensic
experts to go under the of the ICC
to help document
crime scenes
to collect evidence to the highest
International standards
to help the Ukrainian national
authorities and also to provide evidence
to my office in a way that will
facilitate independent and impartial
investigation
since May of last year we've had a
continuous field presence in Ukraine
we've partnered also
with the first time in the history of
the office
with a joint investigative team seven
states now into the auspices of Europe
and we've also tried to build new
Bridges realizing that there is no space
or disinterest there's no space for
spectators
in this battle functions of humanity
this imperative that the law
is rendered effective in this critical
moment
of world Affair it's something for many
reasons
has to transcend Ukraine and Galvanize
us all to do better when it comes to
adherence
of law
and so we've also partnered with the
genocide Network and also the uh and
also your adjust to produce Civil
Society guidance to make sure that those
Brave and uh enthusiastic
documenters can also be given some
guidance
facilitate their work to document as
First Responders and also refer matters
to the National prosecution agencies and
the office
so in the
darkness of the hour
we do have these Rays of Hope
and the lesson that does need to
be understood by all of us all of us are
students all of us we teach is that the
law must be seen to be potent
at this moment is a moment of
opportunity but for us to deliver on
that I will also with respect Echo wise
words if I may say so of the First Lady
of Ukraine
and she said a few minutes human rights
like the air have no border
it's really important and the prosecutor
of the ICC
is not any state or any government and
he's not against any state or any
government
the prosecutor of the ICC
must mean to be a friend of humanity and
a servant of Justice
and the simple truth of the matter is
we need to use this moment all to make
sure
that the concerns that are here in
various parts of the world particularly
the global South
are addressed and we use this moment to
give rise to any arguments of
exceptionalism
or of selectivity
and well before the situation in Ukraine
really went over the Tipping Point
in February uh the 24th of last year
that was the most recent of course
aggression
I said on the 16th of June 2021 a year
and a half ago when I was sworn in
and I'm not in the export business
I'm not selling a product to States
that the Rome statute that I have to
that I've sworn to uphold
and apply
independently and impartially
it is not the law of Italy the Geneva
conventions are not the law of
Switzerland
and I said that for a reason
I continued that this law that we apply
is not the property of the global North
any more so than it is at the global
South it unites
people
because it is the Lost Property of
humanity
the Islamic world in the Christendom you
look at the talmud you look at the
teachings of Confucius or Buddha that in
all countries in all cultures in all
nations in all people
resonate
or find voice
in the mental principles of humanity
that bind us together
and I think this realization
that who is a friend for justice and who
is an enemy
to those that would commit genocide
crimes against humanity or war crimes
anywhere in the world provide this or
constitute a singular moment
for us to come together and do better
across the world
we've tried to show that dynamism in a
number of situations
in Libya last year we applied for new
warrants we've tried to increase our
field presence not only in Kiev
in Cox's Bazaar or in Caracas and in
other parts of the world we're trying to
move forward with confirmation hearings
in Joseph uh Coney case to move forward
and if we seize this moment of
opportunity if we realize we greater
acuteness
the law is not something that can be
taken and left it's not part of an A La
Carte menu
that who can choose what we want
this dark moment this moment of
uncertainty for Ukraine
can be a moment for us to re
together as Humanity
and show
the victims the survivors the very
courageous people that are going to
speak
in a moment
that from Kiev to Cox's Bazaar
from khakive Khartoum
International Justice
is on their side
and if we do that
perhaps we can move
or positively in a better Direction
to make finally once and for all
in the 75th anniversary of the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
be
deliver on the promise of Never Again
and the prayer of a world with more
Justice and less crime thank you so much
[Applause]
uh thank you Mr Khan for those powerful
remarks I just want to close this
session
by thanking our distinguished ministers
for their insightful sobering and
important uh observations
uh given the time I'll just close by
saying this
I want to recall what this building is
all about
this building
is about
the international
rules-based order
and upholding it
and Russia's aggression has been
the most glaring vitiation
of that of the U.N Charter and of what
this manifestation uh this institutional
manifestation is all about
and so as every one of our distinguished
ministers has observed accountability is
essential
staying steadfast in our Resolute in our
resolution to end this conflict
and to bring accountability is our
mission
so with that I will close this panel
thank you all for your remarks
[Applause]
more of you while you're here I know
thank you
foreign
another one
thank you
your excellencies esteemed ambassadors
we are about to begin the first of two
interesting panels I welcome everybody
to take a seat and thank you for your
attention
once again your evidence is your
excellencies as team ambassadors
distinguished government officials and
our honored guests this will be the
first of two panel discussions with
Witnesses uh this one is entitled The
violations of the rights of prisoners of
War
there will be a q a session time
permitting which is why I'm trying to
get everybody to their seats we
encourage you to ask questions during
this first and second panels when we
have our honored guests with us to help
us in our deliberations going further uh
and uh my name is Andre dobrianski I'll
be the moderator for this panel I am the
chair of un Affairs for the Ukrainian
World Congress which is the
international assembly of Ukrainian
non-governmental organizations
representing over 20 million people I
would also like to acknowledge uh that I
am joined as always in this chamber by
my good colleague Dr Martha kebalo chair
of the commission for the United Nations
for the World Federation of Ukrainian
women's organizations also registered
with ecosac along with Ukrainian World
Congress
uh to every extent that it is possible
the organized Ukrainian diaspora has
been dedicating numerous Services
focusing our attention on this war
however uh this panel is related to
crimes that are even beyond our
comprehension
the willful killing torture or inhuman
treatment willfully causing great
suffering or Serious injury to body or
health of the Ukrainian prisoners of War
are all grave breaches of the Geneva
Convention relative to the treatment of
prisoners of War
the emergence of information about these
crimes brutal war crimes committed by
the occupying Force against Ukrainian
prisoners of War has coincided at times
with the revelation of crimes against
detention facilities as well
as an International Community
we have heard of the uh of the special
U.N repertoire about crimes being
committed against civilians and today we
hope to open up the dialogue a little
bit more about the war crimes committed
against prisoners of War which is again
against International Convention
I would like to introduce our first
Speaker our first speaker is Ilya
samuelenko a hero defender of mariopol
he is a former prisoner of war
he joined his regiment in 2015 when he
was still a 21 year old student at
University
he was a history student
and yet he left to join the war he
paused his education and went to
mariopol shortly before the great events
of February 2022 which shocked this body
as well as everybody around the world
uh you may have heard him because of his
uh Valiant defense of the city of
mariopol and staying within the oz of
style steelworks facility until his very
last day communicating with the
International Community uh and we were
very grateful as an International
Community to have a voice directly from
that facility without further speaking
on my part I would like to present Mr
samuelenko
greetings to everyone
um
big honor and somehow a pleasure to be a
participant of great meetings of this
level
uh first of all I want to start just
from the little beginning from the story
like to let you know a bit better about
what we're doing who I am I'm a deputy
commander of the National Guards Ukraine
Brigade as well yeah uh
our unit was defending Mario Paul
alongside with other neighboring units
for 86 days
uh
we've been fighting against overwhelming
enemy Firepower enemy
aircraft's enemy Personnel armored units
they've been overpassing us on in all in
all accounts but not not you know
actually
they were never as motivated and as
dedicated as we are and right now like a
lot of ukrainians are forced to be
soldiers forced to be on the front lines
they never chose this path
they never wanted to be soldiers and
like you know one year ago a lot of like
hundreds of thousands of people in
Ukraine would not just imagine that
these days during these days they might
be a soldiers
uh when the battles started like as
formerly said like there's no turning
back uh and we've been fighting 86 days
uh in total isolation uh Indian
circlement and to the nearest forces of
Ukrainian Army it was like almost 100
kilometers but this story is not about
combat actions yeah but
it's mostly about the human rights and
humanitarian questions
but my opinion and my point of view as a
military person that's the solution to
the humanitarian problems it lies on the
battlefield
uh I will not like tie the blanket too
much on the combat aspects yeah because
like you know it's for the other types
of meetings but uh we heard a lot of
words today about the Russian atrocities
that they've been doing to the civilians
about Mass Graves about uh rape plunder
about uh deporting of children about
deporting of regular civilians about
filtration camps that are also seen
about uh inmates in captivity the
prisoners of War who also treated like
well far from ideal I might say uh
and these are just the top of the
iceberg these are the just the things
that we can uh investigate these are
just the things that are unveiled
uncovered because uh we are recapturing
our territories regarding the zoom liman
uh harki region uh regarding the
harasson region on the south of Ukraine
you should know that uh without
liberation of Ukrainian territories
like 80 maybe much more percent of their
atrocities and crimes will still be
uncovered undiscovered unveiled and
uninvestigated and we cannot allow that
we cannot we cannot allow that to happen
uh for the last year Ukraine
you know we became his spearhead of the
world fight against the Tyranny against
the oppression against the like
Collective evil yeah and the world
somehow right now is United and somehow
is separated between uh
you can support we we
there are sides in this in this war yeah
I actually and but it mostly like not
not my uh sphere of competition because
like I'm a military person I know what I
do
uh and like I know what I should not do
I'm a guest in this world uh like all
these events meetings yeah like for the
last couple of months I became uh rather
um often participant of the events like
this but in a couple of days I will
return to my Battlefield to my to my
world
uh where our ukrainians are struggling
each day
um first of all we started these like
somehow testimony uh just about like to
show my story yeah but
it's just my story there will be a
couple of more other stories by other
speakers yeah but you should know that
there are hundreds of thousands stories
that cannot be told and they will not be
told because these people are silent
these people are dead these people are
under Russian captivity in Russian
captivity uh they are under the
occupation on on still unliberated
territories
and
I might say again yeah the only solution
to humanitarian and human rights problem
lies on the battlefields because
um
you know how it works
the one thing that happened to Ukraine
that we became a battlefield again like
hundreds of years ago like
dozens of years ago in a previous Wars
but this war is like it's it's much
worse comparing to the uh classic
maneuverable Wars of Third Generation in
20th century we can stream it online
yeah and uh you know uh we also been
somehow streaming online the combat
actions in Mario Paul and that's how the
world knew about what is happening
uh what happened in Mario poll and in
other cities is actually basically
genocide we've seen this in the Russian
tactics military tactic it's not just
about the recent bombardments of uh
residential buildings it's not just
about the recent attacks on the civilian
infrastructure uh not just about uh
vicious attacks with long-range cruise
missiles uh for the civilian objects you
know because in mariopo and in Turkey if
we seen it's like
part of military tactics
on of the ground forces because like if
if they're putting their strategic goal
to destroy our infrastructure that's the
one point but if they are putting other
goal uh to destroy uh houses houses of
people where they live
that's the basically a different point
uh we've seen that in tactics in
variable when they've been performing
indiscriminate bombings on the civilian
houses they also been doing this in
kupianskin in many other cities but in
maripo I witnessed this with my own eyes
basically actually one eye yeah the
other one is artificial
um and
not just the bombardments rocket strikes
multiple launch rocket systems Naval
artillery Naval Rockets all these
barrage of arms dropped
on the civilian
white buildings
and tens of thousands people died there
and these human rights violations like
severeu human rights violations cannot
be uh still
investigated properly as well as the
other atrocious crimes committed by the
Russians regarding the inmates in
captivity the prisoners of War for
example the terrorist attack that
happened in the Lenovo prison on the
July 29th cannot be properly
investigated because like Russians are
not putting uh letting in the delegation
of the proper organs to investigate that
yeah and what happened back then like
most of you probably know but uh a
couple of hundreds people were
transferred from one Barrack to another
one and if the Barrack was basically
blown up exploded from inside
uh people basically died in their sleep
peacefully like you know me as a
prisoners of War like I know I know how
it feels because like Russian captivity
is not just like it's not what it's not
what you think it's not uh like still a
place for a vacation after a long after
a long period of enduring battle uh it's
the
like have you ever seen the movies about
Gulag yeah well just just imagine that
but a bit worse yeah because
um we've been frequently asking about
the conditions how it was there how do
you feel how do we felt but it varies
from the places where you are upholding
it varies uh from the uh shifts that are
taking you inside it varies from the how
how sadistic they might be because
the Russian fantasy but in in this
direction like is well well honestly
Limitless
but Russians can do only two things good
they are like shitty at everything they
can do only do things good they can lie
and try to intimidate just don't catch
up on their lives and just be don't be
catch up on their intimidation and
everything will be fine and also
uh right now what I see that Russians
challenged the world order of collective
defense yeah of civilized agreements of
uh all these things that we really get
used to uh all these things that makes
our lives better because we're
negotiating we're talking we're
communicating and we're making things
better
they challenge that not just one year
ago they challenged that uh nine years
ago well exactly nine years ago when
they started the invasion and occupation
of Crimea and uh
this is when everything started but
they've been preparing the grounds for
this for many decades before and the
world was a bit hesitant I I guess I
guess I guess we we were we were
hesitant we were not so decisive not so
resilient not so determined as we are
right now because right now I see that a
lot of good people in the world were
trying to cooperate we're trying to
break through through the walls yeah
we're establishing new mechanisms we're
establishing new parts of uh like how we
should live in this world yeah and this
is rather good feeling
but it's a Bittersweet feeling because
every day when we are like talking yeah
every day of hesitation God's lives
every minute of hesitation costs lives
I want to remind that like I've been
telling this in my uh streams from the
as of style plant uh nothing changed
since then nothing changed the
hesitation means lives the hesitation
and the time of waiting while we are
just preparing organizing something yeah
uh this means that people are still
holding in captivity people are still
under occupation and only God knows what
happens to them because as I said before
there are hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of stories that will not be
heard by us because these people are
silent
ah
these stories should not ever been
happen
because as I said ukrainians being
forced to become
soldiers but
you know it's very good and I'm I'm
proud to say that that we are not just
soldiers we're a warrior Nation
and
thanks God like we have like our pride
and your support support the Free World
and
a lot of words already been told by the
officials by the people who are in
charge here and
you know for me as the like
a relatively lesser men yeah because
like I'm just a the front page of of my
of my kind yeah I present my unit and my
country and I'm proud of it
I'm proud to be here and I'm very happy
to be here actually and this happens
only because like after my captivity in
Russian prison in Moscow in solitary
chamber I was released I was released by
the
Collective actions of Ukrainian
government the president the president's
office you know the the gur
intelligence agency uh the coordination
staff yeah that the presenters are also
here present today yeah and I want to
say great thanks to all these people who
are involved in this process because
otherwise I will not be sitting here
talking with you and uh you know being
in this wonderful City in this wonderful
country and have an ability to return to
my wonderful country
so
as a conclusion I will finish with only
one well-known word as the for the
Triumph of evil the only thing is
necessary is the good men do nothing
thank you
thank you illah I will once again remind
everybody that we will try to get in a q
a session both in this panel discussion
and the one immediately the Raptor for
those who who are I'm encouraging you to
sign up for questions uh uh please sign
up for the list at the checking stations
and we'll try to get to those towards
the end of our remarks today our next
speaker is Mr artem de Blenko to my left
for those of you who are still looking
uh we do have a QR code for the program
if you need to cite anybody's name for
your question uh Mr artem was a marine
who was among several hundred Ukrainian
fighters who returned from captivity uh
only a few months ago he also defended
as of style in mariopul and he was twice
recognized with the night of order for
courage following his uh latest release
only a few months ago uh he very
publicly stated if hell exists then I
have been in it twice first then as of
so Mr artem the floor is yours
dear ladies and gentlemen here is the
man who had the local now like someone
who had been in Russian captivity
but five months ago
I waited 40 kilogram less
all my reaps
some of which were broken
could be counted usually
all I had to do
was just to take off my t-shirts
when I look at in the mirror in the
field day after Exchange
I did not recognize myself
you have the opportunity to see now
what I saw in the mirrorland
I think the difference is the viewers
until February 24
I leave it in peaceful Nikolai City
run a small business
including Bay in the head of the
Region's largest news agency
which of the part past 20 years has been
promoting to the rule of law
the voice of democracy and fighting for
human rights
everything has changed in the moment
when I read the dictator Putin from a
neighboring country decided to destroy
our country
I like tens of thousands of children
ukrainians immediately joined the Armed
Forces to defend not on our country
but also the ideological values
to which Ukraine has been
driven all the years science again
science gain independence
Breaking Free from
presentations in 1991.
together
with ordinary ukrainians like me who
defended marupa
we can talk for a long time about those
days of Defense about tone bombs with
the Russian droplet
on the head of the city
but now
I want to talk about something else
I want to talk
about my camera desk who remain in
captivity
of the occupiers who came to our land
I was a Russian captivative 125 days
this is about 3 000 hours
3 000 hours of physical moral
psychological abuse
three thousand hours of Russian hell
do you know what a walk in Russian
captivity is
is any uh
forced to run past Russian sadist who
bet you with hands
feet and sticks
is it hard to call
what we were felt food
Justice it's difficult to call those who
abused at me and my brothers human
beings
those
who continue to abuse thousands of
ukrainians in Russian torture chambers
there are no Awards
but can convey all the horrors Allah
happening there
I understand that Seeking Justice from
the Russian Federation is the same as
Seeking Justice
from a serial killer
he plants in Gold Blood sins through the
blood crimes kills and tortures
but tries to discuss himself and related
to be a greatest humanitarian in the
world
this is what the Russian Federation is
actually doing today
coming to A great land and come in gonna
fight against ukrainians
today
I'm looking for justice in this building
we're just doing it was representative
the United Nations members stayed
together it whether law is not just a
war
and respect
for each other Israel
I'm looking for help in this hall for my
brothers
because
whether I know they have no weapons to
equalize the chances in the
confrontation with the Executioner
there are no bulletproof vests to
protect themselves from batons there are
no first aid kids to trade themselves
because whether or not even basic first
aid is totally out of the questions
all they have is faith and love in their
head
for their Homeland and their families
from they
whom they went to defend
but especially
this Priceless Faith Russian tortoise
and persistently trying to break
there is no peace where I was
there is no Humanity
where was human rights mean nothing
where I was where was only suffering and
waiting for this
and of course this itself
in the cell where I was a prisoner died
of torted in my arms
I can hardly forget everything I saw in
Russian captivity
but this is in your power to make
something
that there will be less people like me
you have the power to stop the torture
and abuse of Ukrainian prisons of War
captured
on the all native land by their freshest
or
who have no idea what dignity is
you can help Ukraine to bring all the
heroes home
today favors as soon as possible
little lamb asking from you
we will stop this war with our victory
we'll stop in it with terrible cause
the cost of Life of our best people
we are stopping this war with the help
of your support and the unity and the
unity of the entry civilian War
for which
we are sincerely grateful for you
but I am being
you to do everything what is in your
power to save
those who are now
in this very moment
in enemy Uprising and fighting for their
lives and dignity
thank you for your attention
foreign
thank you to our to prisoners former
prisoners of War who are testifying
today often in this body and
international discussion we talk about
numbers and today especially these two
panels we are not only privy to hearing
directly from the people the people that
these crimes affect directly but as in
the case of our next speaker uh
prisoners of War are people and people
have families and with that I would like
to introduce Miss natala husak who is
here representing the association of
families of prisoners of war in Ukraine
thank you so much
good afternoon my name is Natalia husak
I am a wife or prisoner of war
and today I represent all the families
of prisoners of War who were captured
on behalf of all the families of
prisoners of war in our group I would
like to express my sincere gratitude to
you for your sins or desire to help the
Ukrainian people in our trade situation
and we appreciate the opportunity to
convey to you our problem and important
importance of each solution
we once again draws the world's
attention to the fact that thousands of
lives of Ukrainian prisoners over under
that treat every day every minute
we live in constant stress every second
we worry and fight about the lives of
our Defenders children's
husbands Sons daughters brothers sisters
we were talking while talking about our
worries and at the same time we
understand that there could have be
enough of
no such worries if Russia had it had to
the principles of international
humanitarian law
the rules of conduct and what so
existence adopted by the International
Community were rudely brutally and
cynically related by the Russian
Federation
thus mothers and tutors suffering As a
treat of starvation is is this is what
Russia broadcasts by its actions
currently and lawlessness especially
Vivid obvious and evident in the
treatment of other prisoners of war in
Russia and in the temporarily occupied
territories of Ukraine
what we see we see the Russia is the
latent conventions bending on all
mankind provisions of international
humanitarian law commitment crimes
against humanity
we don't see a proper response to Russia
illegal action or Guardian first
violation of the right to life
the Russian Federation constantly
violates article settings of the Geneva
Convention related to the treatment of
prisoners of War here enough to the
convention which advises the Humane
treatment of prisoners of War
everyone has the right to life and no
one has the right to infring upon it
however
in the context of Russia captivity he is
not an external
acts of torture
humiliation of an hour and deity are
carried out by the Russian Federation
against all prisoners of War which
violates the European Convention of
Human Rights
right to life prohibition to tour
second safety assurance
in violation of the Geneva Convention
Russia is hold and capture Ukraine
soldiers in ordinary regime panel
colonies failing to convert the previous
presence in into Paul camps
in addition many prisoners offer are
held on the territory of the so-called
deep air or LPR
where there are constants versatilities
the Geneva Convention clearly stipulates
the prisoners of War captured in the
combat zone but be educated as soon as
possible to camps located at a
sufficient distance from the danger zone
the conditions in this camps must be
novelist favorable than those enjoyed by
the troops holding them captive in the
same area
guarantee of health and provision of
medical care and services Ukrainian
prisoners of war is Russian captivity
have ever limited access to Medical Care
according to this those who have been
returned from the Captivity Medical Care
is provided only in emergency cases of
severe several injuries and illnesses
when the inaction of the regular medical
staff of a hospital or prison can lead
to death of a prisoner of war
Ukrainian prisoners are for who because
of participation in hostilities have
such surrounds fractures amputation of
different degrees
injurious from Shell fragments
post confusion syndrome remain without
antacute medical care during the entire
time of their captivity
for
condition of the tension of Ukrainian
prisoners of War
the conditions of Detention of Ukrainian
prisoners or for on the territory of
Russia and on the temporary occupied
territories of Ukraine which are
deliberately created created by the
aggressor state
a violent and inhuman
lack of food and drink in water
insufficient medicines and lack of
proper Medical Care lack of bets
overcrowding of detention kills
poor Sanitation
lack of basic personal huge project
products warm clothes
five
nutrition of Ukrainian prisoners offer
in captivity
there are a number of Acts of violation
article 26 chapter 2 of the generic
convention relative relative to the
treatment of prisoners of War
which stipulates that the basic daily
food restaurants shall be sufficient in
quietly quality and variety to keep
prisoners of war in good health and to
prevent loss of ways or the development
of nutrition deficiencies
six
the right to information about prisoners
or for correspondence received or
particles
families of the Defenders of Ukraine for
a long time
and tomorrow will be the year when many
of us
don't know receive information from
other relatives who are in captivity in
Russia
I'm so sorry
we turned off where our relatives are
detained their state of health
we have not been able to contact them
for months
meanwhile according to article 1772 of
the convention we have the right
to know information about the state of
health
condition of the tangent of detention
and to have their opportunity to
communicate with our prisoners of work
to give them little medicine Clauses and
others
but this right is not provided to us
accordingly the rights of the families
of prisoners of War and the prisoners
themselves are violated
seven
the right to monitor the rights
we once again draw the world's attention
to the importance of visiting places of
the tension of Ukrainian prisoners of
War
even in the absence of full permission
from the Russian Federation we ask for
your assistance
to ensure that the responsible
organizations in particular the
International Community
Red Cross Representatives
have the opportunity to the least
partially inspect the places of
Detention of other Defenders this will
be a significant step towards the
observance of their rights
and the aggressor's compliance with
International humanitarian law
known of the released Ukrainian
prisoners of War
so a representatives of international
organizations known
eight
release of no known combatants
Ukrainian Medics and musicians of
military Orchestra who are considered
non-combatants under the convention can
be held captive in Russia for almost 10
months
non-combatants cannot be the direct
object of an arm attack of the enemy
because undy combatants they are not
subjects of violence on a military
conflict
as defined by the
foreign
[Music]
accordingly when detained by the enemy
in the course of hostilities they
shouldn't be considered prisoners of War
however they are in the Captivity of
Russia Federation
finally I would like to appeal you to on
behalf of thousands of Ukrainian
families or prisoners of War
we ask you to Faithfully develop the
proper practice of implementation of the
Geneva conventions and prevent
violations of their provisions
we ask to immediately
facilitate the relies of all ukrainians
prisons of War who belong to the Armed
Forces but don't directly participate to
hostilities non-combatants
and provide assistance to them
we ask for support in establishing a
mechanism to be able to systematically
keep to touch with our prisoners or for
and to provide them with little
medicines closings as other stuff stuff
as well as to facilate the responsible
outsources to carry out visits and
inspections in places of Detention of
Ukraine prisons of War even in the
absence of full permission from the
Russia Federation
since Russia doesn't comply with the
standards of humanitarian law and in
fine just on the life and health of
prisoners of War we the families of
Ukrainian prisoners of War
Believe In Justice
strange and effectiveness of
international law
and count on other understanding support
and effective steps towards this Rescue
of Ukrainian prisoners of War
each of them is someone's son husband
father brother mother daughters
all of them defend the Ukrainian people
with honor and dainty
and now with thousands of ukrainians
of fighting for the right to life of
each of them
we will fight for the their rights as
long as necessary
please
say a lives of our dearest relatives
thank you
[Applause]
thank you natala as when I make you for
the first time yesterday your words
really open our eyes to the plight of
not just what we see on the television
not just what we read in news reports or
telegram channels but that all of these
events have a real human toll whether
you are on the battlefield whether you
are supporting those people on the
battlefield and especially when the
battlefield has come to you in your home
uh our next speaker
sometimes sometimes it's good after
working 24 hours a day to see a familiar
face so I'm really glad to see my friend
ihor on this panel because perhaps 10 10
years ago we would have been discussing
other things and doing a poetry reading
at this time of year but instead
after his service here in this country
returned uh and joined his brothers in
arms in Ukraine
um and today ihor sabiha works as the at
the coordination headquarters for the
treatment of prisoners of war in Ukraine
Igor the floor is yours please
thank you
ladies and gentlemen colleagues like
a lot of my colleagues here in this row
I also have my
own small story
a few years ago I used to be a as a
Ukrainian Diplomat seven here in New
York as a Consul general of Ukraine New
York
last year
after Russia attacked Ukraine
I voluntarily joined a Ukrainian Armed
Forces
then I was sent to
the next region is a Frontline place and
a bit later I
joined a wonderful team of cognative
office for prisoners of War
so now
yeah
I work there
coordinative headquarters for pause
it's a it was formed last year on March
and is headed by the commander of
Defense
intelligence of Ukraine General budano
it is a state structure that includes
representatives of Ministries
departments and all law enforcement
agencies in Ukraine
it organizes prisoner exchanges with
Russia monitors compliance with
International humanitarian law regarding
prisoners supports families over
Ukrainian soldiers who have disappeared
or are in captivity legally
socially
the issue of Ukrainian prisoners of War
a story
and important in Ukrainian society and
is
under great consideration of Ukrainian
president zielinski and his team
according to Geneva Convention
all exchanges are to be done
after the war
nevertheless despite this
we freed almost two thousands
ukrainians
107 of them are civilians
Ukrainian women
now
now I want to draw your attention how
Russian Federation organized the
Detention of pause
I mean the list of the main gross
validation of human rights of prisoners
of War
Russia why your lights
the right to life
Russia holds holds prisoners of War as
criminal criminals
Russia does not provide proper Medical
Aid
Russia holds prisoners in humiliating
conditions
Russia does not provide sufficient food
Russia does not allow prisoners to
contact their relatives
Russia relates the right to monitoring
and Russia refuses to release
non-combatants
today
of Ukraine Ukraine and
our headquarters for pause
provides a unique work
and services in 21st century
and we are ready to share
with our experience with you
and
the last thing I want to say that the
key factor of successful exchange of
prisoners of War
is Ukrainian Armed Forces
and let's remember
saving the world as the one
life you are saving the whole world
slavo cream
glory to Ukraine glory to Heroes
thank you
I'd like to now turn to uh just going to
change the schedule just a little bit
and our Milana okay so we're going to go
to uh the executive director of public
international law and policy group uh
Professor Melinda stereo
okay hold on we're gonna switch please
ignore what I just said uh uh we have
been joined by the next speaker
according to my program so I will give
her a chance to draw a breath and then
introduce our Excellency Miss Linda
Thomas Greenfield permanent
representative of the United States to
the United Nations a member of
president's cabinet with Minister rank
Madam ambassador
Brian and the other co-sponsors for
bringing us together for this sobering
but vitally important Side Event
one year ago Russia launched its
unprovoked illegal full-scale invasion
of Ukraine
the same day President Putin delivered
an outlandish speech in an attempt to
justify his war of aggression
Putin told the world he was invading
Ukraine to protect ukrainians from quote
unquote bloody crimes
of course this was a total Distortion of
reality
it is his own forces that have carried
out atrocities against the Ukrainian
people
and we've just heard about the tragic
circumstances of pows and their families
as we made clear this week
the U.S believes Russian forces have
committed crimes against humanity in
Ukraine
crimes against humanity this is not a
determination we make lightly but in
this case the evidence is overwhelming
the independent International Commission
of inquiry on Ukraine established by the
Human Rights Council in March of last
year and the U.N human rights monitoring
mission in Ukraine have documented a
wide range of atrocities and other
abuses committed by Russian forces
summary executions
arbitrary detentions
torture rape and other forms of
gender-based violence and sexual
violence
and we know women children older persons
persons with disabilities and other
marginalized groups are most vulnerable
to these attacks
last November I traveled to Ukraine and
I met with victims of Russia's war
crimes
women who had been tortured by Russian
forces
elderly people who had been kicked out
of their homes
children who want wanted nothing more
than to go back to school and see their
friends
it was gut-wrenching
as a mother and grandmother I am deeply
disturbed by the horrors being
perpetrated against Ukrainian children
credible reports indicate Russian
officials have orchestrated the transfer
relocation re-education adoption or
fostering of thousands
of children
some of these children have been often
during the war and some were already
living in institutions for serious
health health needs
in many cases parents sent children to
what they thought were summer camps for
their child's safety but were then
denied contact and reunification with
their children
in other cases parents refused to send
their children to Russian camps and
Russia's occupation authorities enrolled
them anyway
and let's be clear
this is not some offshoot operation we
have evidence that President Putin and
the Kremlin are actively engaged in this
effort to deny and suppress Ukraine's
identity
their history and their culture
and we must call on Russia to end this
inhuman campaign
return children to their parents and
their Guardians provide registration
lists of the children it has removed
and allow independent observers to
access facilities within
russian-controlled or Russian occupied
areas of Ukraine and inside Russia
itself
the United States also condemns credible
reports of abuses against persons with
disabilities
Russia's war of aggression has
compounded the significant attitudinal
physical and environmental barriers
faced by persons with disabilities
it is that much harder for these
ukrainians to access services including
accessible shelters safe evacuation
options and Health Services
and persons with disabilities face
disproportionate risk of neglect and
abandonment including by their own
families in some cases so we must ensure
that when the International Community
rebuilds from this terrible War persons
with disabilities are at the Forefront
of decision making and policy making at
all levels
colleagues I want to highlight the need
to renew the Mandate of the independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine at the upcoming HRC session in
Geneva
since last March when secretary blinken
first determined that Russian forces
have carried out war crimes in Ukraine
and since the commission found
reasonable grounds to conclude the same
the evidence of atrocities and other
abuses has continued to mount
the commission must be able to continue
its critical work and I urge the HRC to
renew the mandate
there must be accountability for
Russia's atrocities
and mark my word
there will be accountability for
Russia's atrocities
but right now what the Ukrainian people
need most desperately
is peace
as President Biden said during his visit
to keep this week and I quote President
Putin chose this war every day the war
continues is his choice
our message to President Putin is this
in this war
in your campaign of brutality in the
suffering your forces have wrought on
Ukraine and on the world but until that
day comes we must all stand with Ukraine
we must all stand behind the U.N Charter
and we must all stand for accountability
in the face of unconscionable human
rights violations thank you very much
and thank you madam Ambassador for your
remarks and we thank you for emphasizing
the word peace which is often Left
Behind uh again in international
discussions about the conflict uh as we
have been reminded throughout uh this
period since the full-fledged aggression
began uh a year ago this week that
membership in this organization is in
accordance with the charter of the
United Nations which is open to all
peace-loving states accepting the
obligations contained in the United
Nations Charter those obligations
include that members shall settle their
international disputes by peaceful means
in such a manner that International
Peace and security and Justice prevail
our next speaker can speak to that at
length she represents the public
international law and policy Group pilpg
which has advised and consulted with
numerous states around the world
promoting the utilization of
international law and Advising numerous
governments and non-governmental actors
throughout the world about protecting
human rights and Prosecuting atrocity
crimes with that Professor Malena stereo
the floor is yours
thank you so much I'm very glad that
it's about 1202 in which case I can wish
you a good afternoon otherwise I was
beginning it precisely noon in which
case I did not know whether I should say
good morning or good afternoon so thank
you for those thank you for the
introduction it is absolutely an honor
and a privilege to be here with you
today as you mentioned I'm here on
behalf of the public international law
and policy Group which is a Nobel Peace
Prize nominated NGO which has been
working tirelessly on accountability and
documentation in Ukraine since start
since the start of the war including
also working with the United Nations
Commission of inquiry for Ukraine the
pilpg continues to tirelessly work on
accountability justice and documentation
in Ukraine my remarks today will focus
on four topics which I believe are
particularly relevant for the war in
Ukraine first basic protections afforded
to pows under International humanitarian
law
second IHL protections extended to pows
who are seriously ill
third icrc access to pows and fourth
prisoner exchanges under International
humanitarian law I will I will conclude
my remarks by offering some brief
conclusions in light of the relevant IHL
Provisions which I will first outline so
first what what are some basic IHL
protections which apply to prisoners of
War
under IHL prisoners of War are afforded
specific rights and protections these
rights are outlined in the third Geneva
Convention of 1949 and also an
additional protocol 1 of 1977.
some key provisions of IHL relating to
pow's include first the definition of
pows Article 4 of the third Geneva
Convention defines a pow as any person
who falls into the power of an enemy
during an international armed conflict
the status of a pow is not affected by
any unlawful act they may have committed
prior to their capture
additional protocol 1 further expands
the application of this principle by
establishing the prisoner of war status
is granted both to groups of armed
forces and to anybody taking part in the
hostilities
the third Geneva Convention and
additional protocol one stipulate that
where doubt arises as to whether
somebody is entitled to the status of a
pow status shall be determined by a
competent tribunal and not by the
detaining power
very importantly mercenaries and spies
do not benefit from pow status under
Articles are 46 and 47 of the additional
protocol one
second how are pows to be treated pows
must be treated humanely and they're
entitled to respect for their person
their honor and their convictions
they're entitled to receive adequate
Medical Care food and clothing
pows must not be subjected to torture
cruel treatment or any form of
discrimination
next repatriation pows must be released
and repatriated without delay after the
cessation of active hostilities
if a pow cannot be repatriated
immediately they must be interned in a
camp until the end of hostilities
Fourth Judicial guarantees pows have the
right to a fair and regular trial if
they're prosecuted for any acts
committed during armed conflict they
must be informed of the charges against
them and have access to Legal Assistance
and finally communication with the
outside world pows have the right to
send and receive letters and cards as
well as to receive packages and Parcels
they're also entitled to have contact
with representatives of protecting
powers and humanitarian organizations
in some International humanitarian law
imposes clear obligations on states to
treat pows humanely and to afford them
with basic rights and protections
second what about seriously ill pows
under the third Geneva Convention of
1949 wounded and sick prisoners of War
who are seriously ill or injured and
require medical treatment that cannot be
provided in the camp where they're held
must be released and repatriated as soon
as possible
in fact articles 109 through 117 of the
third Geneva Convention provide that
prisoners of War who are seriously
wounded or suffer from specified
diseases must be repatriated directly
back to their own country or to a
hospital in a neutral state
article 110 then sets forth the specific
conditions governing such such decisions
so for example those whose diseases or
wounds warrant a direct repatriation
include the incurably wounded or sick
whose mental or physical fitness seems
to have been Gravely diminished the
wounded or sick who have recovered but
whose mental or physical fitness seems
to have been Gravely and permanently
diminished and the wounded or Sikh who
according to Medical opinion are not
likely to recover within one year
those who may be accommodated in a
neutral State include the wounded and
sikhu's Recovery may be expected with
one year or sooner if treated in a
neutral country and pows whose mental or
physical health according to Medical
opinion is seriously threatened by
continued captivity but whose
accommodation in a neutral country might
remove such attract such a threat in
some IHL Provisions are clear that pows
who suffer from serious medical illness
must be repatriated or at the very least
accommodated in a neutral State
immediately
third icrc access to pows under IHL
states are obligated to allow the
international Committee of the Red Cross
or the icrc access to prisoners of war
and other persons deprived of their
Liberty in relation to Armed conflicts
this obligation is outlined both in the
Fourth Geneva Convention which applies
to the protection of civilians in times
of armed conflict as well as in the
third Geneva Convention which applies
specifically to the treatment of pows
article 143 of the third Geneva
Convention provides that the detaining
power shall facilitate visits by
representatives of the icrc to POW camps
and all other places where pows are
detained
the icrc has the right to repeat its
visits and to receive reports on the
conditions of detention and the
treatment of pows
similarly article 126 of the fortuneva
convention provides that the icrc shall
be granted all necessary access to
persons deprived of their Liberty in
relation to Armed conflicts including
civilian internees detainees and other
persons whose Freedom has been
restricted for reasons related to the
armed conflict
the purpose of such icrc visits is to
monitor the conditions of detention and
treatment of prisoners and to to ensure
that the provisions of IHL are being
respected these visits can help to
prevent abuses and ensure that pows and
other internees are being treated
humanely and in accordance with their
rights under IHL
thus IHL imposes a clear obligation on
states to allow icrc Representatives
access to all detained pows and other
civilian detainees
fourth and last prisoner exchanges
prisoner exchanges are legal under IHL
provided that they're conducted in
accordance with the rules and principles
of IHL including the third Geneva
Convention
article 118 of the third Geneva
Convention provides the pows shall be
released and repatriated without delay
after the cessation of active
hostilities this means that the at the
end of an armed conflict all pows must
be released and repatriated without
delay
however during the course of an armed
conflict prisoner exchanges may be
conducted in accordance with the
provisions of the third Geneva
Convention
article 109 of the third Geneva
Convention allows for exchanges of pows
subject to certain conditions and
procedures
in addition article 8 of the third
Geneva Convention provides that no
prisoner of war may be sent to or
detained in areas where he may be
exposed to the fire of the combat zone
nor may his presence be used to render
certain points or areas immune from
military operations
this means that prisoner exchanges must
be conducted in a manner which ensures
the safety and protection of all pows
in conclusion in light of the relevant
IHL Provisions which I have just
outlined the following conclusions may
be drawn drawn any detained Ukrainian
who has taken direct participation in
the armed conflict is a pow it does not
matter if this person has committed some
wrongful act prior to their detention
all pows have to be treated humanely any
mistreatment of pows is a violation of
international humanitarian law and it
has become abundantly clear in light of
the testimony of my colleagues today as
well as in light of other similar
testimonies over the past year that
Russia has mistreated pows and has thus
committed clear violations of
international humanitarian law
next while pows can be detained during
the duration of the conflict seriously
ill pows must be repatriated Russia thus
has a legal duty to repatriate Ukrainian
pows who are seriously ill such pows
cannot continue to be detained
States also have a clear obligation
under IHL to allow icrc Representatives
access to pows as well as other civilian
detainees Russia is thus also violating
International humanitarian law by not
allowing icrc access to the pows and
other detainees that it is currently
holding and finally it is clear that
prisoner exchanges are legal under IHL
while IHL does not impose a duty on
states to engage in prisoner exchanges
such exchanges are legal and in fact
states are encouraged to exchange
children and those who are medically in
firm and thus all States including
Russia are encouraged under IHL to
engage in such prisoner exchanges and to
conduct them in a manner which ensures
the safety and protection of the
individuals being exchanged thank you
for your for the for for the time that
you've given me today and I look forward
to any questions at the end of this
panel
thank you Professor stereo once again
remind anybody who's still interested in
questions to go to the check-in to make
sure that we have time for that later on
our next speaker and presenter has been
investigating crimes uh against
illegally detained Ukrainian citizens on
The Sovereign territory of Ukraine such
as those areas of the Crimean Peninsula
and the dunbas since 2015 in 2016 the
Ukrainian non-governmental organization
the media Initiative for Human Rights
was launched and since that time she has
been since that launch she has been the
coordinator at the media initiative
which investigates crimes committed in
connection with the occupiers aggression
in Ukraine they document forcible
disappearances improper Detention of
prisoners and track War trials and the
quasi-legal system within the occupiers
territory with that
[Music]
I present you
thank you very much for this opportunity
to work in this very important area
I wanted to talk to you about Miss Ruth
Miller Hussein a woman who was detained
in Donetsk region uh two years ago
before The full-scale Invasion she
witnessed not only the crimes of the
Russian Federation committed on the
territory of Ukraine after the February
of 2024
but also she can tell you about the
occupation that took place since
February 2014 when the Russian
Federation began its aggression I'm glad
to meet Ludmila in these walls after
three years of her illegal imprisonment
but I also only have five minutes with
you to say a few very important Saints
first of all Uh Russian Federation
um
the Russian Federation has been
detaining Ukrainian citizens in an
occupied territories
we could talk about uh of about 4 000
persons whether they were a military on
or uh with civilians at the same time
the Russian Federation did not Define
military personnel as prisoners of War
but called civilians such as Ludmila
that were detained for their
pro-ukrainian position
was they call them a spies and um
uh Divergence and we know then since uh
February 24 22 the practice of detention
continues
um after that uh Russia had about 8 000
Ukrainian
um servicemen
um
this happened both of occupied
territories near cave surrounded mayuple
and captured Kirsten as well on the
front line the Russian side detains and
relocates Ukrainian military personnel
violating the Geneva convection
uh also the Russia is doing detention
after
February 24th even as before they see in
them spies and saboteurs
only in cave region which was liberated
at the end of March 2022 we counted
123 persons who disappeared
123 civilians a majority of them are
held in the pre-trial detentions and the
territory of Russian Federation belga
Road okurski regions and also an
occupied Crimea with regard to some of
them we received answers from the
Russian Federation that the reason for
the attention of just simple drivers
construction workers or journalists
because they were doing so-called
special military operation these people
are actually hidden from the outside
world they do not provide information
about their condition either to their
families or to the state in total we
counted 921 civilians who are currently
in the occupied territories
or on the territory of the Russian
Federation but this number could be at
least five to seven times higher because
many civilians are detained together
with the combatants as as it was done
until February 24th and fourthly the
number of women among the Denise has
increased significantly if until
February 24th the Detention of military
women was an exception then after we can
talk about approximately 500 to 700
detainees
and the 12 months of following the
invasion only 161 women including
civilians were released how many
civilians were detained it's again
unknown first of all due to the
impossibility of access to the occupied
territories and limited contacts with
them but we can definitely say that
special conditions of detention are not
created for women which should be
determined by the gender
that women are subjected to torture uh
military women and also civilian we talk
to the women who came from
from there
before 24th of February and after one of
the soldiers Olga who was released from
captivity and and she told me a terrible
thing she recalls they told me to take
off my shoes I took off my shoes he a
Russian soldier took off my socks he put
my feet in the water and I and he
started running the current I asked him
not to do that you can imagine
it's important also to know that the
process of search for the detained
people it's very difficult first of all
civilians and also prisoners of War
Russia hides places of detention and
constantly moves people including Inland
and everyone knows that some people for
example from cave region were moved five
times at least we don't know where they
are now
when we ask them where these people are
a Russian Federation mostly it's quite
they don't say anything
we ask at least 10 different agencies of
the Russian Federation where about
whereabouts of these people and the
answer was silence
I also a secondly it's important it's
impossible to obtain information about
the conditions of the tension it is
difficult to say what happens in
so-called colonies pre-trial detention
centers or basements where prisoners
were kept Russia does not allow
representatives of international
organizations to visit it in these even
representative of the international
Committee of Red Cross that now have
prisons but in reality they are not
persistent enough to get there the third
is that Russia is not ready to release
wondered Soul wounded soldier as a
priority and stop the practice of
turtles they are not ready to release
civilians if they are elderly or have
problems with health
firstly there is no existing mechanism
for release of thousands of civilians
since the practice of change does not
apply to them they do not apply the
Geneva Convention maybe the there is a
need to create a special negotiation
platform for the release of civilians
and involvement of negotiators on the
highest level for the whole year even
more for nine years Russia has been
destroying Ukraine ukrainians torching
torturing the military for their
resistance as well as kidnapping
civilians for their disagreement with
the occupation and this happened since
2014.
it is a systematic practice of the
Russian Federation and we all should
know about it a lot of people have no
right to express
um their thoughts and do not have their
right to Freedom thank you very much for
your attention
there we are
change your schedule
um so for those uh who have announced
their presence we have uh questions and
answers today I know that we have
several representatives from different
non-governmental organizations who have
already
voiced a request for comments so first I
would like to turn to the International
Red Cross for their comment
almost
you see a green
thank you
just awaiting the microphone there
um
there we are thank you
[Music]
thank you very much and good afternoon
um I would like to acknowledge the
difficult stories we have heard this
morning and also the hardship of
thousands of families seeking for news
of their loved ones
um and pass also two messages on behalf
of the icrc uh the first one and as it
was mentioned by the panelists all
prisoners of Wars are entitled to
receive a regular visits from icrc
Representatives under the third Geneva
conventions
um while the recent visits we have
carried out our up to a positive
progress
um we still need to see an impeded
access repeated visits
um and visits that are held privately uh
to happen
um so for the thousands of people that
we have not visited yet
um we also want to shed light on their
right to receive such visits for us to
assess their condition and treatment to
share awaited news for their families
and also to provide essential assistance
my second message is also about
information about prisoners of war and
protected civilians um that are deprived
of Liberty and this information needs to
be shared so the icrc has created uh
specifically
um the central tracing agency which is a
dedicated Borough that establishes
specifically a setup to help alleviate
the suffering of families who remain
without news we have received and
supported thousands of family requests
but we know that many deserve an answer
and are waiting for information so we
will remain committed committed to
continue those visits but also making
our best on behalf of the People
Protected in this situation thank you
thank you very much for those remarks we
also have a request for comment from
Human Rights Watch
okay
um
thank you for giving my organization
Human Rights Watch the floor the
anniversary of this conflict is a
sobering location Human Rights Watch has
been on the ground since the beginning
of the conflict in Ukraine and by
beginning I mean 2014 eight years before
Russia's full-scale Invasion last year
documenting human rights violations and
atrocities including rape summary
executions and unlawful attacks against
civilians and civilian infrastructure
attacks on hospitals
schools and recent targeting of key
infrastructure that provides heat and
electricity
we have published at least 94 items on
the conflict since February 24 2022
reports press releases articles videos
and other items documenting violations
of the loss of War including possible
crimes against humanity
the overwhelming majority of violations
have been on the Russian side though we
have also documented Ukrainian
violations
a few examples last April we produced a
report on Russian forces atrocities
against civilians in butcha
which people rightly found horrific
others quickly confirm our findings we
documented the abuses on the Russian
filtration system four supportations of
civilians to Russia and areas controlled
by russian-backed separatists torture
kidnappings and other violations
yesterday Human Rights Watch and C2
research published a new report on last
year's Russian attack on the Crematory
train station using illegal cluster
Munitions that kill at least 58 people
and injured over 100 more we have also
documented Russian Russia's invasions
Global impact exaggerating a food crisis
in the Middle East and North Africa and
the world we will continue to document
abuses by all sides and call for
accountability for war crimes we welcome
the international community's commitment
to accountability for the countless
violations of international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
we hope that this desire to ensure there
is accountability is a model for its
model for other situations I thank you
thank you very much for those comments
I'd like to present one last speaker for
this panel uh Miss Ludmila husseinava is
also a representative of the Ukrainian
NGO the media Initiative for human
rights my apologies for not recognizing
you sooner but miss Lumina the floor is
yours
my name is I am 60 years old and 2019 I
was detained by the representative
so-called
um
but these people had a Russian passports
and I know it for a fact
uh they searched my house and they found
books by tarashevchenko Ukrainian
language also they found other books in
Ukrainian language they also found
Ukrainian flag and this became a reason
to put me an isolator
and this where the
most terrible days in my life during
this isolation period I did not see
anything I was there with a suck on top
of my head all the time
they forced me to take my clothes off
they touched me only men were present
there
every day they were constantly we were
monitored by video cameras they prohibit
us from 6 a.m to 10 p.m be sitted on the
chair or maybe lie down on the bed once
I was so tired and I just sat on the uh
uh on the on the seat and I was beaten
heavily I was um lucky because my family
member looked for me for a month they
paid a lot of money for a lawyer and
this lawyer found me and was able to get
me out from that isolation
cell to another
prison in Donetsk region there I was in
the cell with 20 other women women that
were had criminal charges against them
they used drugs they were killers and
they tried to
do the same with me that Russian
soldiers did against me and I was not a
and
alone there that was a situation with
the women that were there for political
reasons these people like me were there
together with the criminals and this is
done uh specially because these
criminals were given instructions to do
anything possible against us this
practice they do already for three years
during this years I have seen my lawyer
maybe only six times
this is the practice when for more than
three years being in prison I saw the
investigation investigate about five
times this practice
when you are not allowed
um any kind of meetings with your loved
ones when your loved ones uh do not hear
from you they don't know how they live
that's a practice when they do not
provide any medical care whatsoever this
is a practice when you do not go out for
walks and in three years if I maybe
walked for about 20 minutes on land on
the ground when they were taking me from
one place to the other that's all I had
this is a practice when in the last
months of being in that prison they
didn't let us out for walks they didn't
give us the possibility take showers
they uh we didn't have any kind of
possibilities to have any basic
basic services and comfort
things and in this minute while we are
talking there in the prisons
entertainments at least there are 20
women in the donets detainment center
that are there for over three years
three four years
I wanted to tell you about one woman or
have a Russian when she was
detained her son the youngest son was
four years old she has not seen anything
from her husband for four years she
hasn't heard any she hasn't heard his
voice but she's sitting there without
uh the Court decisions without an
investigations nothing and the heart is
just breaking and the pain is
overwhelming I want I wanted to tell you
that I took this document my judicial
conclusion with respect to those
torturers they were taking care of me if
I could say that and I will testify
against them I want them to be punished
I want the evil to be responsible and be
punished and I'm asking you very much we
know that there is no mechanism to
liberate the mechanism uh liberating the
civilians well then come up with this
mechanism make sure that these mothers
these civilians these sisters
um to be liberated to uh to let go
because their souls are broken their
hearts are broken they do not see their
children
I'm asking I'm pleading with you please
uh do anything you can to let women go
free so that they could return to their
children
thank you
uh
this is the first of three panels uh the
following panel uh will begin promptly
at 3 P.M uh I would like to thank uh all
of the panelists assembled all of the uh
diligent work uh by The Diplomatic Corps
for making this happen that doesn't just
include the Ukrainian Diplomatic Corps
but also all those who made sure to
participate today listen and uh add
comments uh as I mentioned earlier it
when I when I was struck by seeing my
good friend ihor sebiha again uh a
decade ago we would be uh we would be
organizing cultural events as opposed to
events like these and in fact nine years
ago this month we were scheduled to
honor the life and work of Ukraine's
national bird tarasiochenko as was
mentioned by Ludmila in the Echo sock
chamber
coins were minted especially for the
200th anniversary of his birth for the
program at the United Nations and that
program had to be postponed by a month
it was postponed because in the early
pre-dawn hours of February 26 27 2014 uh
the enemy stayed to the north of Ukraine
uh entered Ukrainian territory and
violated its sovereignty it has remained
there to this day it is through the
efforts of our International Community
uh not least of which are good friends
at the International Red Cross that we
realize how uh to treat our fellow man
in times of distress for my great
grandfather that was uh thanks to the
International Red Cross tending to him
after he served in the austria-hungarian
Army in Italy and I have the paperwork
to prove it
upon his return to his native country he
did not raise a gun again in fact was
quite against having any military
Association at all but he was a
dedicated teacher until
the enemy to the north of Ukraine once
again collaborated with the fascist
powers of Central Europe and invaded his
hometown of Street
and when I go visit that town I can
stand in the prison cell where he was
bound and beaten to death
by the occupying state to the north of
Ukraine he was beaten to death because
he taught in the Ukrainian language
which is something that to this day
is attempted to be erased as we
mentioned as Ludmila mentioned uh the
books that have been disappeared uh and
that is in stark contrast to the ideals
uh of this body this body uh and its
predecessor the relief and
Rehabilitation Administration which
tended to my father who happened to end
up in a displaced person's camp and was
given every opportunity by the Western
Powers who were taking control of the
Occupy of the newly liberated territory
in in Germany and was recommended by a
U.S major in the Air Force to apply for
a scholarship here in the United States
there are ways that we treat our fellow
man and there are ways that
unfortunately uh parts of the world uh
dedicated people who are dedicated to
harming their fellow man unfortunately
do not live up to the ideals of this
body
with that I would like to once again
thank all of our speakers today I would
like to thank all of your presents today
and remind everybody that once again we
will be gathering at 3 P.M for the
second panel followed by the third and
closing panel of the day at 5 pm today
thank you very much
thank you